un récent sondage sur l'économie révèle
que bon nombre de jeunes actifs éprouve
toujours des difficultés qu'ils
agiraient de la génération du band
l'origine hausse en matinée par les ans
pour cent de la génération oblige
financiers
je tiens à vous remercier d'avoir
accepté de me parler vous allez avoir
l'occasion de raconter votre propre
histoire pouvait faire ça pour moi j'ai
un super taf c'est juste une start up
mais qui sera parfait pour le job
alors c'est pas le boulot
[Musique]
enfile savant descendu
il volait tout ce qui avait de la valeur
et ils détruisent elle reste pour
s'amuser c'est grâce à melle donnelly
qui se faisait de l'argent de côté un
nouveau gars sans me demander vous
l'amener sur mon lieu de business j'ai
rien vu du tout je crois bien que si
je t'interdis tu parler de ça à qui que
ce soit ou tu le regretteras
tout le monde sait qu'une poignée de
personnes possèdent toute la richesse et
ils ont pas envie que ça change
on se contente pas de voler
on envoie un message
si l'un de vous envisagent de partir
tout seul de son côté le visage de teddy
sera la dernière chose que vous verrez
n'a pas été franc avec moi une seule
seconde mais vous avez fait le choix de
vous compliquer la tâche
tu crois que j'ai pas de plan on veut
faire de mal à personne la vraie
on peut dire que ça s'est super bien
passé pour toi
c'est la fin mais qu'est ce que t'as
foutu
[Musique]
on préférerait être mort plutôt que de
soumettre système